[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in sallys welt
fachen zur ramadan zeit haben wir die
küche richtig schön hergerichtet ich
finde ich richtig richtig toll geworden
und heute gibt es ein süßes rezept
nämlich süße karamell schnitten und die
könnt ihr super vorbereiten und jetzt
gerade zur ramadan zeit entweder abends
dann mal als dessert serviert oder eben
wenn dann die ramadan zeit vorbei ist
und das fastenbrechen und alles vorbei
ist dann könnt ihr das ganze auch als
dessert servieren wenn ihr zb feiert
richtig schön und ich habe mir auch
gedacht ich nehme ein paar orientalische
zutaten mit rein gerade datteln die man
eben zu ramadan zeit ganz oft zu hause
hat und einfach verschiedene zutaten die
das ganze so ein bisschen unterstützen
ich zeige euch mal eben kurz die zutaten
den ofen habe ich schon vorgeheizt auf
170 grad ober unterhitze darf er nämlich
150 gramm entsteint datteln 150 gramm
heißen kaffee 150 gramm weiche butter
und 150 gramm braunem zucker etwas salz
zimt und vanille extrakt 2 1 250 gramm
mehl backpulver oder ihr verwendet das
bak mehl 100 gramm walnüsse und 100 com
milch ja das war es eigentlich schon
also was jetzt zuerst tun könnt erst mal
die weiche butter in die rührschüssel
geben
und dann
könnt ihr das ganze mit dem braunen
zucker und salz schon mal verrühren
[Musik]
gibt da wo ich auch gerne schon wandel
extrakt und sind dazu und während es
hier dann etwa drei bis vier minuten
cremig verrührt wird kann ich nämlich
schon mal die dattel nehmen dem ich
bereits entsteint und das sind jetzt
datteln ich glaube die sind sogar vom
vorher aber das macht ja gar nichts die
werden nämlich nicht schlecht das kann
nur passieren dass ein bisschen trocken
werden deswegen solltet ihr sie auch mit
dem kaffee einfach schön pürieren oder
wer kein café möchte kann auch einfach
heißes wasser oder einen heißen saft
dazu geben hauptsache sie werden weich
und wichtig wie gesagt dass sie in stein
sind das kann ich schon mal in der
zwischenzeit machen
[Musik]
perfekt und dann kann ich jetzt hier dem
masse dazu geben dies ist schön fein
püriert wie ihr sehen könnt und falls
ihr keine datteln da habt könnt ihr zum
beispiel auch dattel sirup benutzen da
ist dann einfach schon flüssig das ist
dann ein bisschen einfacher oder weg
sagt können dass er auch hohl und dann
einfach schön einweichen und dann kann
ich das hier verrühren und gleich noch
die eier dazugeben und auch schön cremig
werden
[Musik]
da kann ich jetzt hier schon mal die
wahl müsse einfach nur grob hacken
könnte auch wenn ihr keine wahl ist gern
haselnuss mandeln oder andere müsse
verwenden
er von unseren bisschen zerkleinern und
ich mache jetzt gleich eine eckige
schnitte aber wenn ihr möchtet dann
könnt ihr auch immer gerne in meiner app
vorbeischauen und da die maße einer
ruhigen backform zum beispiel ein geben
falls ihr den kuchen rund packen möchte
und dann rechnet die app automatisch die
ganzen zutaten zu und muss zunächst mal
rum rechnen wir früher immer
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich einfach alle zutaten hier
in die rührschüssel im wechsel immer so
ein bisschen mehl etwas milch
und die wahl müsse und dann könnte die
zutaten gerade noch kurz einrühren
[Musik]
da könnt ihr euch den bug rahmen auf die
perfekte größe einstellen ich mache
jetzt hier 30 x 25 cm und dann wird der
hier eingestrichen und kommt sofort in
den backofen
[Musik]
richtig
ist es das
el assad riecht lecker und wenn es
lecker es muss ich probiere du siehst du
musst aber sie muss jetzt erst mal
gebacken werden okay also kommt jetzt
der kuchen in den backofen und spart so
ungefähr 30 minuten bei ober unterhitze
170 grad dann auf jeden fall ein
stäbchen probe machen und ich kann in
der zwischenzeit mich aber auch schon
mal um die creme kümmern damit es
schneller zu ihren kuchen glück kommt
[Musik]
der kuchen selbst gebacken und auch
schon abgekühlt jetzt geht direkt an die
füllung eigentlich wollte ich was mit
karamell machen aber ich bin noch so
bislang hin und hergerissen weil jetzt
gerade die sonne da ist und wenn sonne
da ist dann ist mit karamell war ich
überlegte mir gleich nach aber ich hab
mir gedacht machende quark sahne creme
und pflaumenmus hier mit rein ich glaube
das wird der hammer das ist glaube ich
richtig gut für die quarkcreme nämlich
500 gramm quark 80 gramm puderzucker
etwas vanille extrakt 400 gramm sahne
seiner par zum steif schlagen etwas
zitrone pastor wenn ihr möchtet und zum
füllen noch etwas pflaumenmus das war's
schon
jetzt gibt dir einfach den quark eine
rührschüssel
dann puderzucker dazu und vanille
extract
dann kurz verrühren
dann gießt ihr hier langsam die sarah
dazu
[Musik]
und schlag dann die creme mit seiner
partei
[Musik]
die creme stelle ich jetzt kurze den
kühlschrank
dann könnt ihr jetzt hier den bug rahmen
entfernen nachdem ihr ihn gewirkt haben
[Musik]
und dann können wir jetzt schon mal den
kuchen ganz gut einteilen mit worten
einteiler zum beispiel
drücke ich nämlich ganz vorsichtig
so ein bisschen an und er hat einmal 20
teile auf einer seite und auf der
anderen seite hat er 30 das heißt ihr
könnt jetzt bestimmen ob er das ganze
größer oder kleiner haben wollt nicht
durchdrücken denn es reicht schon so
dann nehme ich einen
ich habe echt wortfindungsstörungen
apfel entkernt einen apfel entkernt und
bau hier so ein kleines loch rein
ansonsten können dass er bei kern
ausschneiden und
nicht bis ganz zum boden durch und ich
könnte seid alle essen
ganz kurze trigger warnung für alle die
unter der lok krankheit der angst vor
löchern leiden es entstehen gleich zwölf
löcher
bitte leg show
[Musik]
und da nehme ich jetzt hier das
pflaumenmus das habe ich jetzt hier
schon mal in eine dose flasche gefüllt
ihr könnt abonnenten im löffel einfüllen
oder mit einem spritzbeutel com
berichtet und dann könnt ihr hier
nämlich das ganze schön einfügen
[Musik]
wir können jetzt mal die kuchenstücke
zuschneiden und falls ihr kleinere
portion und machen wollt dann teilt
einfach die quadrate nochmal ein oder
macht zum beispiel rechtecke also so
gutes in rechtecke ich meine so
längliche rechtecke aber ich finde es
sind jetzt auch nicht so riesige
portionen also es geht jetzt können wir
so ein bisschen auseinander nehmen
damit ihr sie gut dekoriert bekommt
dann die creme entweder ganz normal auf
streichen oder wenn ihr jetzt seine
spritztechnik machen wollt dann gern in
den spritzbeutel füllen zeigt euch auch
gleich die spritztour dazu wenn ihr sagt
ihr wollt weniger arbeit haben dann
wirklich einfach schön auf streichen und
danach zu schneiden oder auseinander
ziehen und ansonsten können das wirklich
schön mit der spritze machen ich finde
es nämlich dann noch ein bisschen
dekorativ kann
und sag ich da vorne dieser stelle
darauf dass so eine flache blatt stühle
und dann nehmt ihr euch ein törtchen und
arbeitet so dass die dicke seite unten
ist und die dünne seite oben und dann
könnte einfach diagonal die creme schön
auf spritzen und ich finde erzählt man
mit so einem ganz kleinen oder mit
seinem ganz kleinen aufwand echten
schönen effekt
[Musik]
sind sie schon richtig schön jetzt werde
ich sie aber noch fertig dekoriert mit
etwas zimt dann nämlich cacau nutzt dazu
das ist praktisch die gebrochene
kakaobohne also die schokolade in ihrer
reinsten form aus kakaobohnen werden
nämlich cacau lips zum beispiel oder es
wird eben fein gemahlen und püriert und
dann enthüllt und kakaopulver und
kakaobutter und dann nehme ich noch die
metallic flex mit dazu denn die machen
das ganze einfach schön wie soll ich
sagen zu reden weil es einfach metall
ist und das ist schokolade überzogen mit
etwas lebensmittelfarbe und die sieht
einfach wunderschön aus
[Musik]
richtig schön gell mit ganz wenig
aufwand und die kommen jetzt kurz in den
kühlschrank natürlich abgedeckt und dann
dürfen sie gleich probiert werden
der kuchen durfte jetzt durchziehen und
jetzt darf youtube probieren
dass ich fast nichts über den ramadan
weiß echt ich weiß nur dass man ab
sonnenuntergang bis sonnenaufgang ist
genau
also da ist jedes jahr zehn tage früher
weil der islamische dass islamischer nur
elf monate hat die richten sich
praktisch nach dem vollmond was
eigentlich muss ich auch sagen mehr sinn
macht wenn man so dem vollmond überlegt
und deswegen sind die monate immer c
also im christlichen kalender dann zehn
tage früher das heißt der ramadan ist
nicht wie weihnachten immer am 24
dezember sondern der immer zeitversetzt
wird immer früher und dann hat man eben
den ramadan mal im winter hat dann im
herbst an im sommer und so ist ja immer
früher ok und wie lang geht 30 tage 30
tage bei uns sind
ja und es ist schon muss ich sagen recht
streng weil man halt wirklich von
sonnenaufgang bis sonnenuntergang nichts
essen nichts trinken da also somit essen
finde ich dass das netz so schlimm aber
das trinken ist schon da muss man schon
diszipliniert sein und ja und ab wie
viel jahre eher man sagt so ab der
pubertät also wenn also kinder müssen
nicht mitmache schwangere kranke
menschen müssen dann damit machen aber
so ab der pubertät sollte man das schon
dann mitmachen und halt jedem selbst
überlassen als ich weiß auch jetzt schon
wieder dass viele wieder fragen werden
fasste tier und wie macht ihr das
umfasst eure kinder aber das ist einfach
so etwas privates und das gehört auch
wenn ich noch offenen kanals ist muss
jeder für sich wissen und darf jeder für
sich entscheiden was ich dazu sagen muss
wir drehen alle videos immer vor
also sieht hübsch aus
sehr schön mit den metallic leer und das
ist so was
gab's immer so richtig auf jeden fall ja
dann greift sie ja gerne
ich komme aus einer ecke mit metallic
flex
mit dem
müssen und
dem teig keine zukunft
wieso brauner zucker aber dass die
frische kommt durch die zitronen passte
zwar recht gut das team habe mir zum zum
pflaumenmus kommt
richtig gut weil
den hat immer lockt mit stimmt dabei bis
ihr könnt ja auch wenn ihr merkt blaue
muss wollte einfach ein bissle mehr
einfüllen mehrere löcher rein stecher
weil du bist fast
perfekt das passt perfekt dazu denn das
dach wirkt als wenn man so die schnitte
seht wuchtig schön samtig recht gut net
so süß und konnte mich durch und cremig
drehen also
manchmal sind unsere beschreibungen so
logisch creme de la creme
also probiert das rezept gerne mal aus
ihr findet in meiner app da könnt ihr
übrigens auch die zutaten hoch und
runter rechnen so wie ihr das braucht
und ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachbarn bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]